well,
both with a doubt cristian cásseres
consult the news now in
spanish a man accused of killing a
child and leaving his body in a freezer
will appear in court on wednesday
we are talking about a program within the
35-year plan that could face
murder charges later  After the boy's body
was found inside a
residence near Care In Line, the
detectives believe that he also held
the boy's mother against her
will since December.
I tell you that Clark County
firefighters fought a fire.
incident near sunset park it all
started early wednesday
on waltz easter fence authorities
believe the incident started with a
vehicle which then spread into
nearby brush police assisted
to close streets around the
fire in what firefighters were
controlling  the fire
gender police make an
arrest in connection with the kidnapping of an
11-year-old girl  Josep Pomar,
21, faces various charges including
sexual abuse of a minor. Detectives
say that the kidnapped minor was
found on Tuesday afternoon. At the
moment, there are no details about her state
of health and the winter system continues
in our region.  that left rain
winds and even
snow today we will have cloudy skies
with a slight chance of rain
Thursday will be sunny but it will feel
cold as temperatures will continue to
drop we will have an increase in the
digits for the weekend when
we return to the 70s  Grados I am Cristian
Cáceres with his brief informative of
ignis now in Spanish good day
[Music]